people always tell me that I'm selfish
because I'm not interested in all the
wars that's going on in the world but
the truth is I think that's smart why
would you worrying and get caught up in
all this drama and politics which is
being manipulated by the people above as
always when you have your own problems
in your life you have to save yourself
first I have goals that I need to
achieve I want to save myself first I
want to help my family and how can you
help other people when you can't even
help yourself charity has to start at
home and once you've saved yourself then
of course you can be charitable you can
volunteer you can do all these amazing
things you can be a miracle in
somebody's life and that is definitely
something that I would like to do one
day but I don't have the capacity for it
right now you have to save yourself
charity starts at home first and then
once you've done that you can help other
people around the world